Hello and welcome to the final example we have in this course and in this we're just going to
be using a PCG volume to add actors to the world instead of static mesh instances which
we've been using up to this point. So for this we're just going to be moving over to
slide 4 example 4. In this if I was to press simulate we can see that we have
a whole load of NPCs where I'm randomizing the color and speed and we're having them
running around in. Okay so let's just quickly see how we've done this. So I was to open up the PCG
characters it's very similar to the previous ones. I'm using the world hit rays because I haven't
got a landscape in this instance so this works in a very similar way. Creating a few trees with
our standards static mesh spawner an almost identical setup I'm using a spawn actor and
you can see within this if we were to look down we have the template actor class
is the NPC. There is a bunch of extra options that you can do but mostly in this
we're not going to go into the advanced sections for this. So it's creating the NPC
character. If we would have a quick look at the NPC character you can see that we have a couple
of bits of randomization on the construction script. We're randomizing the speed and we're
randomizing the color here. So this doesn't have to be NPCs it could be buildings could be
anything that is an actor basically and the construction script will run at the point that
it is run. So that's it really. Thank you very much for holding on with us. We've gone through
pretty much we've created a relatively complicated PCG volume from scratch in our forest.
We've used the spline mesh in order to cut through it. We then looked at four
different examples of how you might go about in a different way of using the PCGs.
So hopefully this has been useful to you and thank you so much for joining us.